chin what happen to your car this Ford
so real quick since our stereotype this
is just like our to Asian employees yeah
one racked last week the other lotta
guts car stolen mmm the auto is stolen I
recall this morning this bro I'll be
late my car got stolen take it from
there chin go what happened I didn't
realize it wasn't stolen so I actually
went to the police department and filed
a police report and as I'm following up
cause I went downstairs to the front
desk and I said my car's missing did you
did anyone toe a car for whatever reason
they're like there's no toast lips in
front I'm like well my car's gone so I'm
gonna stole my car I'll go make sure
don't delete this footage you know it's
like a 24-hour footage that runs through
make sure don't delete it I have to file
a police report so I called the police
department three different ones because
Ellie I guess have different parts of LA
nightmare right and they said that I
have to go into the to the station so I
went to the station started feeling it
out and then my department called me
said they've not seen any tow trucks
come in since the time I got there right
which is 7 p.m. 6 p.m. yesterday until
this morning so then I was like ok what
happened and he goes you probably parked
it in the wrong area so what happened
was we just got back from Vegas I was
super tired my car's parked in the 5th
floor of the structure wait and you been
living there how long how long is it in
like six months
ok little odd but scary ok ok you've
been parked it's exactly you go through
the structure everything is the same
right there same so I parked on the
fourth floor instead of the fifth floor
in the exact same space that's a dead
Channel the other I was panting because
those were also a way to work I don't
want to be late to work right got that
headache you've had for two years no two
months that is your headache on no it's
there's not as bad right now but it's
every night heard that she ate the best
movie of the year you're in it right the
Joker mmm yeah game changer I did I did
looting fourth street told me the word
on the street is Oscar I I did I did
that I saw somebody told me awesome it
might be the best joke anyone's ever
seen yeah Heath Ledger says
hold my bike yeah well listen I think
it's gonna be iconic cat so I got it I
heard it did you see like bike yeah okay
yeah I heard it hold my oxycotin hold
might look at that I think it's all
painted then it
no no that's the scene I'm in see what
he's doing there
really yeah that's it awesome scene that
looks like an awesome since at CNN man
can't wait dude it's an update on David
Ortiz
so as six people arrested we called it
side peace and it's supposed to be some
sort of like really highly calculated
scheme to to kill them but you know they
don't know exactly right yeah they do
though but the press is being nice
actually the drug dealers show drug the
cartel member he's on sex with his girl
and then you know who at the at the
hospital where they're doing surgery
Schwindt just found this out when Sir
John him his other side piece and the
cartel side piece start fighting in the
hospital while his wife was on the way
dude
big papa good did the media is doing him
a favor by not blasting this out that's
pretty well known and it was two guys so
they topped the one right that they're
whooping his ass a little in the count
later and yeah I was only eight thousand
dollars to kill Big Papi oh there you go
and that member the first guy was
getting beat up like crazy that guy was
actually just the getaway driver the
other guy took off on foot the guy that
actually shot him - that's him we're
right yeah that's him David Ortiz he's
in Boston LA safe yeah man that's kind
of crazy
definite [ __ ] cartel members girls there
you know she might be hot do we have a
picture of her if you're gonna risk your
life is Big Papi I bet she is just
delicious I have no doubt reinstate stay
low stay on the DRF i if I'm an American
in general well you are Dino also know
there's not a lot of you kill a national
hero a baseball here you think I do a
white gringo yeah but I'm saying when
you do that it's like you I feel like
that guy the people that tried to kill
him my public enemy number one period to
everybody we tough due to the
tell member well I see a cartel member
or just a drug dealer who's he's a car
it's a big time yeah well just get this
news from the cartel stuff Oh chin on I
got it from in fact I got the I got all
of it from one of the no don't say it
then if it's yes it's pretty well know
somebody who knows yeah well and knows
David Ortiz name is Pedro Martinez yeah
just are you rolling yes I'm this
[ __ ] guy comes in with a hat
sunglasses and a gallon of water you
yeah these are my blunt stones these are
my blunt stones okay well looks like we
just started the new ad campaign for
blood haha these are my blood stones
these are my blood stones you got
chocolate in my blood stones you got
peanut butter in my blunder take it easy
guys good new Jesus Christ will sasso is
taking over for Brendan Schaub today
don't just throw things I'm not le ah
[ __ ] it this time yes [ __ ] table man
don't bring has been on the air since
iPods exist right do you know that iPods
don't exist anymore yeah I do
oh you don't yeah I do know don't do the
base thing well I'm not doing the
burying this is my natural resting voice
I don't know about that I'll tell you
something you um [ __ ] this doesn't
brother that's a water-cooler sighs yeah
Tanner Brian okay haha everybody knows
we it's so annoying we that I drink a
lot of water what do you say to people
is when they want to get healthy I go
how many clams you none that's your
first mistake you [ __ ] idiot then
they go on losing my hair I go how many
times you washed your hair twice three
times a week first mistake yeah you're
clogging your pores wash your hair four
times a day four times Gail super dry if
you clean that's all yeah there get a
can of that clam juice you can find it
near your pickled onions in your
groceries clam juice pickled onions my
massage that I'm in a [ __ ] scalp yep
get to the get to the beach sing some
country music and eat some clams massage
intimate lands and leeching speaking of
Italians when I was young yeah my family
and extend
family we would all go to the beach and
the kids would adults would dig clams
and you know pick the mussels off the
rocks up in British Columbia for British
Columbia Canada and then we would just
my uncle John would throw down a like
chicken wire like you're just a [ __ ]
yeah with posts it was awesome build a
fire throw nuts but you're gonna want to
just dump all them so so I'll fish on
there I'll do you one better my mother
lemon my mother in Italy and a lot of
people would take a break take a lemon
yeah they would go and get the mussels
and the clams and eat them raw and eat
them [ __ ] wrong but still does it my
mom still does that true yeah if we get
clams or mussels that moon that moves
like give me one you know what I mean
put my mom I don't want you to I don't
want you to you know we're gonna make
him moister shall eat the moist of
course oysters but clams and mussels
with a little bit of lemon yeah anything
yeah we're right there as you see oh
yeah I think she was in like Sicily or
something yeah I just done for a swap on
the Bay of Naples and they would eat the
[ __ ] right from the sea yeah they try to
get a lemon a problem with that is that
water probably ain't that clean because
everybody in Italy cuts corners so they
dump all this [ __ ] that's true you know
I mean it's like Jerry with my folks
yeah four corners you know Brian this is
the kind of refreshing conversation that
we're supposed to be happy I mean that
and a lot of your listeners have never
heard you speak like that and they go I
learned something right and now they're
gonna go to the beach in 2019 with you
know lemon and they're gonna get
dysentery yeah and they're gonna [ __ ]
themselves
yeah clams just eating clams willy-nilly
at the at this Beach you happen to go to
to me not a good idea
eating mushrooms not a good idea in the
forest Louie Oh in the forest yeah don't
think I'm just eating awesome don't want
to do that and if you don't know what
the berry is don't put that in your
mouth and eat the berry especially if
it's red your RF it's orange or fits or
if it's bright color or even fits Orange
crazy a load don't you keep the backup
or it's red and if it's Fitz blue Fitz
black blue probably a black probably all
right probably nice long strip is yellow
don't but long if it's Fitz Fitz
blue green you didn't [ __ ] away from it
away run away Fitz green Fitz pink get
on different plans yap yap yap yap-yap
it's pink
nan different plan yeah you're doing you
on you got like a new reality shows you
have as a reality no pareo it's not it's
one of those sing you have it's like
Undercover Boss we were actually hell
short so a real gym coach no no your
nope nope nope nope no yo no yes no
you're a cartoon urine guard too you cry
all day long yeah me I hold it back yeah
uh-huh it's always see it's right behind
[ __ ] this is an acting lesson no
wallet three inches behind his face you
guys are gonna do this yeah you guys are
gonna go out there's a chance are you
guys gonna get eaten by notice how karma
talking through his nose her Meredith
let's get acting I eyes I can do - hi
emerald goes and tells about the movie
that she had a little cry alright and it
was [ __ ] unbelievable I'm like she's